bonjour gérard larcher bonjour on vient
de voir le film en accéléré de ce
quinquennat des relations parfois
tendues entre le gouvernement et le
sénat notamment des révisions
constitutionnelles avorter le pic de
tension de la sphère benalla le sénat a
joué le rôle de contre-pouvoir c'est le
titre d'un nouveau livre les relations
avec l'exécutif ont elles étaient pour
vous particulièrement difficile pas
difficile au fond quand on regarde ce
quinquennat et pour le législateur que
nous sommes et pour les femmes et les
hommes politiques que nous sommes c'est
quand même un quinquennat on n'a pas
réussi à retisser
la confiance souvenez-vous il commence
par un congrès à versailles et le
président de la république nous annonce
vouloir construire une forme de
renouveau démocratique oui et il nous
dit aussi nouvelles vouloir tisser de
nouvelles relations avec les
collectivités territoriales de la
république et 80 demi après aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'on constate on constate que
c'est une étude du cevipof y n'y a pas
si longtemps paru dans le figaro que le
niveau de défiance reste extrêmement
élevé et que doute aussi d'ailleurs si
on a écoulé seul élu quand la confiance
des français ce sont les maires et les
conseillers municipaux
donc dans ce premier bilan n'a pas
réussi collectivement retisser la
confiance même si je vais être un peu
chauvin pour le scénar les choses se
sont plutôt mieux passé où on n'avait
pas une cena bassiner vous estimez
aujourd'hui les choses c'est que à la
fin de ce quinquennat
dont on va voir le rapport de la cour
des comptes ce matin on a quand même une
réalité financière qui nous amène pour
le futur à devoir nous projeter et on a
une responsabilité nous les
parlementaires
premier le milliard de dettes tu es
quand même pas rien
une dépense publique qui a augmenté et
je parle même orco id une dépense
publique qui a augmenté à que le quoi
qu'il en coûte nos lois qu'il en coûte
n'était pas inutile ou l'avons même mon
fiancé dans cet hémicycle soutenu dans
la plupart de ces phases mais la réalité
3 milliards de dettes une dépense
publique qui a augmenté
des réalités aussi
aujourd'hui qui sont des réalités très
fortes notamment quand on voit le
déficit du commerce extérieur des
questions de compétitivité au début du
quinquennat un certain nombre de
décisions que là on d'ailleurs soutenu
sur les ordonnances travaille sur des
actions en matière de l'alternance mais
je dois dire que c'est quand même un
bilan dans lequel la déception mais les
relations avec le sénat ont été des
relations
vivante
nous avons voté beaucoup de textes près
de 70% que nous avons voté attention ça
ne se passe pas si mal ça démontre que
nous sommes toujours une assemblée de la
construction ici et pas une assemblée
qui se situe systématiquement dans
l'opposition par principe je disais au
moment j'ai été réélu ici sénat ont dit
jamais oui par discipline et jamais non
pas dogmatisme ça s'est vérifié au cours
de ce quinquennat mais je dis quand on
dit non c'est non je pense à la dernière
proposition de révision
constitutionnelle sur le climat sur le
terme garantis
les observations du conseil d'état était
clair nous analyse était clair c'était
un mot qui luttent et inappropriée voire
dangereux nous l'avons refusé et je
crois que peut-être qu'aujourd'hui on
fait un demi tour sur le nucléaire ce
n'est pas inutile que nous ayons dit non
à quelles réformes constitutionnelles
êtes-vous prêts puisque vous parlez de
celle à laquelle vous n'étiez pas prêts
il y a toujours la question
d'introduction de la proportionnelle
toujours la question de la réduction du
nombre de parlementaires et vous nous
avez parlé de ce tous les filles en noir
de la constitution je vous le rappelle
ça relève d'une décision politique la
proportionnelle à l'assemblée nationale
cc dessus c'est un texte qui n'est pas
constitutionnelle pourquoi nous avons
dit non sur la révision de la
constitution parce qu'il y avait la
question de la représentativité mais
surtout il y avait alors que le
président de la république s'était
engagé en 2010 est au congrès renforcer
le rôle et la place du parlement
nous avions la réduction par exemple du
rôle de la commission mixte paritaire
qui d'ailleurs nous a permis d'abord
j'allais dire d'aboutir dans un nombre
très important de gars tout récemment
sur la loi décentralisation
déconcentration 3ds nous avons abouti
sans la loi et à quelques mois climat
résilient nous avons abouti donc est-ce
qu'il faut réformer tout le temps la
constitution il faut se poser un certain
nombre de questions sur le
fonctionnement traditionnel séder
réformes institutionnelles doivent tête
est automatiquement constitutionnel sans
doute sur un certain nombre de points
mais je crois qu'il faut les préparer et
il faut qu'elles soient strictement
nécessaire
quelqu'un qui est dans cette salle
rappeler qu'il faut toucher la
constitution que d'une main tremblante
la cession va se terminer la semaine
prochaine gérard larcher avec un débat
sur le mali il ya aujourd'hui un mini
sommet à paris sur ce sujet vous allez
voir le premier ministre jean castex est
ce que vous êtes favorable à un retrait
total de l'opération barkan du mali
d'abord rappelé qu'au mali
notre engagement est un engagement dans
la lutte contre le terrorisme
l'islamisme radical le djihadisme c'est
un combat qui est mené au nom des
valeurs est d'ailleurs à l'appel
historique du mali je me souviens très
bien de l'opération serval aujourd'hui
la réalité c'est que nous sommes face à
une junte militaire qui préfèrent les
miliciens d'un groupe privé wagner liés
à la russie
et la situation sans doute qu'on ne peut
pas rester dans un pays dans les forces
politiques juste l arrivée par la force
et hors de tout contexte démocratique de
voeux puis la présence de nos armées et
d'un certain nombre de nos alliés qui
sont à nos côtés
le président de la république chef
désormais en lien avec les partenaires
européens
doit faire le poids savoir dans quelles
conditions on peut continuer assuré
parce que se battre contre le terrorisme
l'islamisme radical c'est se battre bien
sûr dans ces pays mais c'est aussi se
battre
souvenons nous des attentats que nous
avons connus pour des valeurs que nous
avons en partage notamment en europe
savoir comment nous allons réorganiser
cela cela dépend du président de la
république le parlement va être associés
à la réflexion la semaine prochaine
peut-être un peu avec sion avec emmanuel
macron vous allez rencontrer jean castex
est ce que bien sûr - sexuellement je
pense qu'on ne peut pas rester dans un
pays qui nous quittons les forces
politiques même arrivés par la force ne
veulent plus moi je pense à nos soldats
a pigé quand même une pensée
58,58 de nos soldats sont tombés nous
avons eu des centaines de blessés nous
nous sommes retrouvés dans la cour des
invalides ou ailleurs pour leur rendre
hommage on leur doit me semble-t-il au
delà de l'hommage un peu une dette une
dette
de patrie et c'est ce que nous allons je
crois devoir partager au delà des
clivages politiques rinne ne faut pas
néanmoins quitter le sel pour vous on
parle d'un redéploiement au niger et je
vous le disais à l'instant il faut voir
comment nous nous réorganisons on a
évoqué l' niger mais regardez aussi les
frontières nord au delà du burkina faso
de la côte d'ivoire togo bénin la
frontière sénégalaise c'est autour de
cela qu avec nos partenaires africains
nous devrons discuter dans les jours qui
viennent on revient donc sur ce mandat
les deux dernières années ont été bien
sûr marquer au parlement comme pour tout
le monde par la crise sanitaire qui a
débuté dans un climat ici on se le
rappelle d'union nationale ce qui n'est
plus du tout le cas aujourd'hui au fil
des confinement la majorité sénatoriale
a voté néanmoins le pass vaccinale
aujourd'hui elle dénonce aussi un pass
électoralistes est ce que vous regrettez
ce vote non il était nécessaire à cette
époque nous avons d'ailleurs voté la
plupart des mesures avec toujours une
attention particulière ça doit toujours
être proportionnée
proportionnée entre les nécessités
sanitaires et le respect des libertés
individuelles et collectives car nous
avons nous avons admis la restriction
des libertés individuelles et
collectives
l'interdiction de se déplacer
l'interdiction de se réunir
l'interdiction un certain nombre
d'activités souvenez-vous les je ne
pouvais plus aller au restaurant entrer
dans des commerces sauf dans doute ces
périodes de confinement et à chaque fois
le rôle du sénat gardien des libertés
individuelles et collectives
c'est cette réponse proportionnée voilà
pourquoi nous avons mis au cours de
cette période en place et un contrôle
dans chaque commission mais nous avons
mis commission denquête
mission d'information mission
d'information qui va achever sa tâche
qui était présidé par le socialiste
bernard je n'y allais deux rapporteurs
roger karouchi jean michel arnaud et une
commission d' enquête qui suit
d'ailleurs les conséquences sanitaires
qui a lieu sur l'hôpital de même que
nous mettons en place une commission d'
enquête sur l'hébergement de nous aider
dans les établissements spécialisés mais
aussi tout simplement l'accueil de nous
aimer est-ce que mel est ce que le pass
vaccinale pour vous aujourd'hui est
encore proportionnée quand on voit qu'il
ya une vingtaine de parlementaires de
votre groupe qui demande sa levée
immédiate et puis je rappelle que ce
matin olivier ferrand annoncé une levée
possible pour nous mars eh bien écoutez
nous verrons il ya une commission qui
travaille là dessus je rappelle son
titre adéquation entre les mesures
imposées par le pass vaccinale est la
réalité de la pandémie je fais confiance
à la présidente catherine de roche de la
commission c'est vraiment le rôle de
contrôle du parlement on n'est pas
simplement dans la pulsion du jour dans
l' annonce du jour nous avons voté un
texte c'est la loi si la loi doit être
levé parce que nous avons retrouvée et
des niveaux j'allais dire de vie
sanitaire qui soit acceptable et bien la
commission nous le dira mais vous ne
dites pas que ce passé et politique
comme certains on a pu l'entendre dans
l'octroi je dis que je passe et je fais
partie de ceux qui ne votent pas comme
président du sénat j'ai soutenu ceux qui
votaient quelques questions politiques
gérard larcher dimanche valérie pécresse
a utilisé les expressions grand
remplacement ou encore français de
papier ça a été commentée dans tous les
sens 1 depuis critiqué y compris dans
votre camp vous avez toujours représenté
une voix modérée 1 chez les républicains
est ce que vous regrettez qu'elle est
employée ce vocabulaire
migration
sécurité deux échecs majeur du
quinquennat photo qu'on apporte des
réponses à cette question migratoire il
faut le faire dans le cadre de nos
valeurs républicaines et la question
quand on reprend la phrase de valérie
pécresse c'était parce qu'elle n'en
voulait pas qu'on utilise ce terme de
grandissement veulent être le rempart à
ces grands remplace moi je veux des
français qu'ils soient les français de
coeur et c'est ça et voilà pourquoi la
question de l'intégration de
l'assimilation de l'accueil dans notre
pays est un sujet aussi important et
quand on ne maîtrise pas
quand on maîtrise pas les migrations et
bien quelque part ça nous conduit à une
forme de séparation nous avons
d'ailleurs président de la république
avait utilisé ce mot au mur au
scepticisme pour éviter le séparatisme
maîtrisons maîtrisons l'immigration
maîtrisons l'immigration faisons de
l'intégration de l'assimilation ça nous
renvoie au texte sur les valeurs de la
république et sur la laïcité auquel le
sénat ait ré majeur car ban attaché et
auquel je suis personnellement tellement
attaché il ya eu six textes dont vous
nous rappeler l'existence 1 pendant ce
quinquennat autour effectivement de du
séparatisme il ya eu plusieurs lois
autour de la sécurité se sont pour vous
encore des occasions manquées elles
n'ont pas manqué pourtant on nous a
certain nombre de textes nous en fait
avancer même ce que nous n'avons pas
voté je pense aux tec sur les valeurs de
la république je vais prendre un exemple
nous venons d'avoir un débat sur le
sport
vous savez bien
ces jeunes femmes qui viennent voler
devant le sénat qui sont allés
manifester devant le sénat
au fond elles viennent tester si la
république tient bon ou si elle recule
je ne suis pas pour une république qui
recule voilà pourquoi je pense que le
gouvernement a eu tort dans le texte
sport de ne pas de deux arbitres aient
accepté et on est en plein jeux
olympiques il ya un esprit et un esprit
initié par pierre de coubertin qui
s'inscrit aussi dans cette égalité
hommes-femmes dans des valeurs
universelles je suis pour
l'universalisme et l'universalisme ça
fait partie des valeurs de la république
et tout ce qui nous sépare nous devons
être très attentifs et les combattre il
ya une ambiguïté pour vous du
gouvernement sur cette question n'a
entendu les prises de paroles de marlène
schiappa d'elisabeth à moreno j'ai
compris y compris en entendant le
ministre de l'intérieur ce matin qu'il
était me semble t'il plus proche des
positions que le sénat mais moi je ne
juge que dans les faits objectifs
c'est-à-dire le vote le gouvernement et
la majorité n'ont pas voulu à
l'assemblée nationale de la proposition
du cenalt fusion pour le sport ça me
semble révélateur la majorité
présidentielle justement parlons dalal
range désormais valérie pécresse dit
elle je la cite dans le camp de la
droite extrême qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez des mots tout ça c'est des mots
je connais valérie pécresse sans doute
un peu mieux que j'ai par deux fois
était son président de comité de soutien
la région ile de france
je suis élu tu sûr département c'est une
femme qui clairement est une femme qui
se situe à droite ouverte aussi sur la
pensée d'un certain nombre de modérer
c'est une femme qui décide qui fait qui
n'est pas dans les mots dans les
langages quand elle met une charte de la
laïcité en place pour l'ensemble des
activités de la région ile-de-france le
fait sans même temps une femme ouverte
ouvert sur les questions de société
attentive aux autres j'ai envie de leur
dire suivez valérie pécresse comme elle
l'est dans un village ou dans une ville
d'ile-de-france et vous verrez la
valérie pécresse dont le pays a besoin y
a pas besoin d'une clarification
d'aujourd'hui délaissent hallynck
qu'elle soit ce qu'elle est je le
connais bien et je lui fais confiance
elle a tout à fait ce j'allais dire la
dimension pour donner aux pays qui est
tellement fracturée qui est tellement
diffusé et tellement dans le doute je
reviens à ce cette analyse du cevipof
que j'ai évoquée au début de notre
entretien voir un pays dans un tel état
de défiance qui classe le gouvernement
au dernier rang de la confiance qu'ils
placent les maires au premier rang de la
conscience un pays tellement structuré
tellement divisée il a besoin de clarté
pour reprendre une formule de valérie
pécresse il faut qu'on fasse et qu'on
arrête de dire sans faire vous n'êtes
pas inquiet face au sondage du jour
aujourd'hui qui montre pour la première
fois valérie pécresse qui serait d'aller
je le dis clairement
si valérie pécresse n'est pas au
deuxième tour
le président de la république sera réélu
et à ceux qui s'apprêtent à voter qui ne
souhaite pas et sarah deuxième mort de
rire il faut que je réfléchisse bien sûr
c'est tout simplement comme ça une toute
dernière question faut-il revoir selon
vous le système des parrainages qu'il
redevienne anonyme on voit un certain
nombre de propositions notamment celle
de françois bayrou qu'il veut une banque
des parrainages pour les candidats qui
dépasse les 10% d'intentions et les
inventions à
quinze jours de la fin des parrainages
il peut y avoir un sujet j'ai dit que je
réfléchirai
je proposerai la commission dreux et loi
je pense que si des responsabilités très
importante qui est donnée au maire et le
maire d'un petit village chez moi il a
les mêmes pouvoirs que le maire de
versailles dans mon département ça nous
vient d'ailleurs d'un héritage ancien et
cette responsabilité des maires elle est
une responsabilité qu'ils doivent
assumer j'ai déjà dit parrainer n'était
pas soutenir en un temps voit bien que
l'extension de l'anonymat peut conduire
à des pressions institutionnelles
politiques collectives on y est annoncé
je suis pour le maintien du parrainage
par les maires une réflexion après cette
élection devra nous permettent
d'analyser faut-il qu'il soit ne niez
nous qu'ils soient organisés de manière
différente on se donne le temps on
n'essaye pas d'être dans l'invention
quinze jours avant la fin de la période
de signature eh bien merci beaucoup
gérard larcher d'avoir répondu aux
questions de public sénat nous sommes
donc à une semaine de la fin de la
session avant de rentrer de plein fouet
dans la campagne merci beaucoup pendant
ce temps lâche simplement je veux dire
le sénat continuera à travailler les
commissions se réuniront le mardi ou le
mercredi les groupes politiques toutes
les deux semaines et les commission
denquête l'émission d'information les
délégations donc c'est pas les vacances
c'est la poursuite de l'activité au
service du pays de la démocratie vous
continuera à peser sur la vie
démocratique et sur les institutions
deux importants merci beaucoup et public
sénat suivra ça avec bien sûr beaucoup
de constance et d'intérêt merci à chela
[Musique]